[Music]
welcome back to CBS this morning
Saturday we begin this half-hour with a
seafood delicacy that may be loved right
out of existence
it's abalone a shellfish that's
relatively rare on menus here in the US
but in the Far East it's the epitome of
fine dining
Remi Inocencio has the story from Hong
Kong
Hong Kong is a seafood lovers paradise
from saikhan pier with its crabs shrimp
and things you've likely never seen to
sheung wan dried seafood Street with its
shark fins fish bladders and abalone
Eric Chong and his family have been
selling such delicacies the past 40
years abalone is the most expensive
thing he sells a mollusk this is a dish
of extravagance at Chinese celebrations
this is seven hundred dollars worth just
a tea by mayo and soy yo it's not
include you don't think this is
expensive and abalone could get pricier
demand is rising as China's middle class
grows richer high it's part of the
culture he explained the most famous
chefs in Hong Kong make the most
delicious abalone in the world French
born Maxime Jubair is one of them at
Ecuador his two-star Michelin restaurant
a signature dish most Japanese abalone
the most expensive is something that
people love like for us in France a
truffle or foie gras it's really
something for high-level response
Joubert Steam's raises slices and serves
at atop an eggplant puree despite living
in Asia for years I had never eaten
abalone mmm it's very soft the texture
it's like a slightly firmer scallop
exactly I do get tired of eating this no
every time I eat I'm like why so good
but getting abalone from coast to
kitchen can be a criminal process this
is what fresh living abalone looks like
Hong Kong is the world's biggest
importer of this
and it's huge appetite could be funding
organized crime about 7,000 miles away
in South Africa poachers have decimated
abalone numbers one species could go
extinct global NGO traffic which tracks
the wildlife trade says 2,000 tonnes are
illegally fished from South Africa's
waters each year 20 times the legal
limit and up to 60% of Hong Kong's dried
abalone from South Africa could be
poached
that's why traffic's Wilson Lao won't
show us his face he inspects Hong Kong's
seafood sellers how does one know if
they're eating illegal abalone mr. Tong
puts blind faith in his supply oh my
lane I don't ask he said because I trust
my supplier 100% for the world's most
expensive seafood its high price can't
compare to its value as a species on the
brink recipients this morning Saturday
rainy innocencio Hong Kong I've had it
in Hong Kong before but I never knew
that it was that there was that big a
deal yeah the idea that there's an
illegal food that you have to worry
about that you hear about illegal
diamonds something along those lines to
have it like this